what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and it looks like we're
learning a lot more about the Fantastic
Four today we have a working title for
the movie that gives us some Clues as to
what we could expect from the plot and
it appears that the Watcher might
actually be entering the MCU pretty soon
and he might possibly show up first to
work with the TVA he could then show up
in other projects as we explore the
Multiverse even more before before it
starts to collapse and we go into
Avengers Secret Wars but it looks like
we could be experiencing something that
we experienced in what if season one you
to breaking his rule of interference The
Watcher is just supposed to watch he is
not supposed to interfere that is one of
the main roles of the Watcher The
Watcher is supposed to just observe and
compile knowledge on all aspects of the
universe but what happens when the
universe and the Multiverse starts to
get destroyed what does The Watcher do
then well we have a pretty decent idea
and it does involve the Fantastic 4
specifically the ending of the Fantastic
4 and then going into Deadpool 3 and
Avengers Secret Wars we've also been
doing casting updates recently it does
seem like Matt shackman does have his
fantastic forecast and as soon as the
strikes are done it will become official
so we'll talk about who the final
Runners are for the characters in this
video and of course we can't leave out
the villain of the movie galatis and the
Silver Surfer of course who has been
rumored to have a special presentation
coming before the Fantastic 4 so we'll
get to that in a bit and of course if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos and if you subscribe and leave a
comment you are automatically entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items we pick one winner at
the end of each month and that winner
gets to pick one item only a few days
left now so this new report about the
Fantastic 4 working title is coming from
Alex Perez at the cosmic circus.com and
he States this according to our sources
the working title Marvel Studios is
using for the upcoming Fantastic 4 film
is Blue Moon we first cut wind of this
as a working title for a Marvel project
at the beginning of the year however we
could not at the time tie the working
title to a specific Marvel project and
Alex Perez did indeed tweet about this
back in may they go on to explain that a
working title is like a code name when
casting calls go out or when making
deals the code name will be used instead
of the project name to help keep things
quiet working titles at Disney and
Marvel can be nods to Comic lore or even
just in jokes however with a lot of
different Marvel Studios working titles
that they use they often hint to what
the story could be for the actual
upcoming movie and they often hint to
Comic lore and in this case it looks
like the Fantastic 4 working title could
be hinting at the blue area of the Moon
and this I believe could tie in The
Watcher we'll get to that in a bit but
first we'll talk about the story that is
kind of going on right now that the
cosmic circus talks about they state in
Marvel Comics millions of years ago the
Scrolls discovered the planet Hala home
to two races the cre and the katti to
test which race was Superior to share
their secrets with the Scrolls used the
Earth's Moon as a scroll Colony testing
site for the cre and the katti the cre
would build an area known as the blue
area of the Moon which was a thriving
City in Metropolis while the katat
managed to grow life on the surface of
the Moon when the katat were selected by
the Scrolls as the superior race the cre
rebelled and killed the Scrolls and
katti right before abandoning the area
to Decay and essentially become ruins
this event would Mark the start of the
centuries long story of the cre scroll
war in the comics but it's highly
unlikely that's what Marvel intends to
cover in their upcoming Fantastic 4 film
and I agree however right now we have
kind of already experienced the cre
scroll War and going into the Marvels we
are kind of still experiencing that
darbin is right now leading the cre and
she's going to attack Earth and she's
going to attack Captain Marvel so we
still are experiencing some of the cre
scroll War so there could be a slight
tie in however I don't think it'll be
linked because of what we've heard about
where the Fantastic 4 takes place we
have heard that it might take place in
another universe so if that is the case
it definitely shouldn't tie into the cre
scroll war that is happening in our
universe right now and in fact based off
of what we've heard about what could
happen for the plot of the Fantastic 4
the Fantastic 4 will take place in
Another Universe and in that Universe
they are the only superheroes and they
are very famous so no Avengers no
Captain Marvel possibly no Nick Fury
nobody like that to even have beef with
the cre of course the Fantastic 4 could
have but I don't think that's the story
route they're going to go down
especially because we know Galactus is
going to be the villain but the cosmic
circus.com and Alex Perez continue to
state the Blue Moon working title seems
to indicate the possibility that the
blue area of the Moon may serve as one
of the more important settings of this
movie when we asked our sources about
the possible connection between the
working title and the story for the
Fantastic 4 our sources were able to
confirm that Marvel intends for the
first family to make their debut in
Style by starting off with a grand
Cosmic Adventure which is absolutely
awesome to hear especially since we've
heard that galatis is indeed going to be
the main villain of this film we
recently heard the other day from
Insider my time to shine hello that
galactus's Herald in the MCU Fantastic 4
reboot will be a woman now this might
line up with the Fantastic 4 taking
place in Another Universe because there
is a version of the Silver Surfer from
the earth 829 Universe known as Juno so
it is possible that this heral is indeed
going to be the Silver Surfer even
though she's going to be a woman if the
movie takes place in Another Universe
this really isn't a bad idea and this
actually opens up the future of the
Fantastic Four films to have a male
Silver Surfer in the main MCU Universe
moving forward after Avengers Secret
Wars that's kind of the cool thing about
having this movie take place in Another
Universe you can do things that you
normally wouldn't do and still go on in
the future to do things that you
normally would do with the Fantastic
Four for example a rumor that we've
heard is Galactus is indeed going to be
the villain of this film but he's going
to win the Fantastic for will lose at
the end of the movie so if what we've
learned from the working title is true
and the information that the cosmic
circus has obtained is true about this
being a cosmic Adventure it looks like
they're going to run into galatis and
have to defend Earth from galatis at
this point in time if the rumors that
we've heard are true they're going to
lose and their world is going to be
destroyed or at least it's about to be
fully destroyed when the TVA shows up to
save them and take them to kind of a
place between universes and this is
where I believe the Watcher will show up
another one of the Fantastic Four
stories that have to relate to Blue Moon
is one of the Fantastic Fours earliest
outings in 1963 Fantastic 4 number 13
where the Fantastic 4 travel to the blue
side of the moon this is also where the
Watcher makes his comic debut and he
warns them about galatis coming to Earth
The Watcher may warn the Fantastic 4
about galatis in the movie but I also
think that he's going to be monitoring
several different universes just like he
did in what if and I think that he might
be helping the TVA pick and choose
heroes from each Universe to save to be
able to ultimately save the entire
Multiverse if the rumor that we've heard
about the TVA going around saving Heroes
is true it would make sense that the
Watcher would be helping them because
the Watcher knows about all of the
different heroes in all of the different
universes so we could be getting a
liveaction watcher debut pretty soon and
he could be in the Fantastic 4 and other
films if he truly is going to be helping
the TVA and to top it all off like I
mentioned we have a little bit of an
update on the cast for The Fantastic 4
Daniel rpk has recently stated no actor
has signed but the choices would be Jake
Dy Hall as Reed Richards of course
Vanessa Kirby as Su storm Joseph Quinn
as Johnny and ibon Moss bachot as Ben he
also states that there are two unknown
roles including one very important for
the future and Antonio Banderas is still
cited for galatis this could be our main
official cast they just simply can't
officially sign until the strikes end
and for those wondering about Jake
gyllenhal being Reed when he was already
Mysterio we've talked about this before
if the movie takes place in Another
Universe this could work it really could
Jake Gyllenhaal is a great actor a lot
of people really like him and it would
be great to see him take on a main role
such as Reed Richards in the main MCU
but let us know your thoughts about this
in the comments down below would you
like that would you not like that do you
like what you're hearing about the
Fantastic 4 let us know down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest news you can find us on Instagram
and Twitter as well and as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof